ils sont les stars de l'info chaque jour
à 13h ou à 20h une présence quotidienne
à l'antenne qui a un coût et pas
n'importe lequel car vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais être présentateur de
jt sur une chaîne nationale est une
situation plutôt confortable
le salaire d'anne claire coudray ou de
gilles bouleau sur tf1 avoisinerait les
40 mille euros mensuels un chiffre qui
grimpera même à 50000 euros pour jean
pierre pernaut superstar des régions il
ya quelques temps c'est jacques legros
qui révélait sur la chaîne on stoppe
people gagner 2000 euros par jt un
chiffre impressionnant qui rapporterait
au joker du trésor 42000 euros mensuels
un salaire sur lequel il a tenu à
revenir je me suis fait piéger avant de
préciser sa pensée je rappelle tout de
même que lorsqu'on est pigiste comme moi
il ya aussi de longues périodes sans
rémunération et aucune sécurité d'emploi
et puis il faut tout lissée sur l'année
avec l'épidémie jacques legros à animer
chaque jour pendant plus de deux mois le
jt de 13 heures une période qui lui aura
donc permis de mettre de l'argent de
côté alors selon vous les présentateurs
télé sont ils trop payés le présentateur
télé son titre payant vous pose la
question chez bon et en direct dans ses
que du type qui marche de mieux en mieux
je crois vous êtes très très nombreux à
nous regarder encore aujourd'hui je vous
le dis alors les cherry qui dit oui qui
dit non je vais demander l'avis de
raymond dans un instant mais juste
jean-michel 20000 euros donc par jour
pour jacques legros le présentateur du
jt c'est un genre bien sûr que c'est pas
un jour je serai ce n'est pas moi le
sujet non non j'ai bien bossé mais il
dit ça mais il ne fait pas tous les
jours il travaille que deux mois par an
alors on va revoir la vidéo de regarder
la vidéo de la wii et je vous parle
journal télévisé oui quelles questions à
vous poser combien je gagne ça c'est
très indécent de vous demander ça non
parce que parce que moi je suis un cas
donc je ne suis pas un employé permanent
de tf1 je suis payé au journal d'accord
ok et un journal c'est combien un
journal sais c'est pas loin de 2000
euros d'accord ok ok je suis étonnée je
pensais que c'était beaucoup plus
sincèrement
voilà donc si c'est sur nos stops et
paul l'instant de luxe avec mon avis un
projet mental
alors c'est quelqu'un qui se livre chez
jordan
les prédateurs sont ils trop payer 2000
euros par émission je sais ce que c'est
voilà ce que pour revenir justement il
dit j'ai été piégé n'a pas du tout été
piégé il ay là il a ouvert son coeur à
jordan de luxe il a dit ce qu'il avait à
dire
après sur le coup et sédiments
ce peut-être que ça va faire réagir il
s'est rendu compte que ça fait réagir et
donc il dit rétropédale ce jardin de
luxe leur donne six jours aux gens
qu'ils interviewent si éventuellement on
a envie de couper par ya des choses qui
nous viennent des côtés mais si je joue
ma pour pouvoir couper là la mission
après six minutes alors mais est ce que
est ce que dans ce nom il répondait à la
question moi on très honnêtement je
trouve qu'il faut jamais répondre à ce
genre de questions parce que de toute
façon c'est toujours de jouer mais néc
tu es donc la question les présentateurs
télé jaune entre employés mais là il a
trop payé ils sont payés à l'échelle du
monde de la télévision et il incarne
quoique ce qui est encore n'en déplaise
à certains la grand-messe ça reste
encore la grand messe à rennes 13h15
le carrefour oui à 13 heures et à 20
heures c'est des moments très importants
d'une chaîne de télévision notamment tf1
chaîne jeu que je rappelle privé donc
ils mais ce qu'elle veut avec les
salaires c'est pas notre argent s'est
passé voilà c'est pas le mien c'est à
l'agencé en garder un petit peu d'argent
a ajouté m donc voilà donc c'est une
chaîne privée fait ce qu'elle veut
maxime ben non ça me gêne pas parce
qu'être présentateur d'un jt c'est
l'aboutissement d'une carrière d'une
expertise ils peuvent fait ne peuvent
parler de tout ils ont une
responsabilité et à bien après il ya des
différences notables de chaîne tf1 est
la chaîne qui paye le mieux
là il évoque 2000 euros par part
insulter brut
quand même les pij est donc évidemment
quand ils les papés bas une touche mais
c'est vrai si on fait une petite
comparaison un saut pierre pernaut on a
sauté capitale qui avait révélé ces
chiffres étaient cinquante mille euros
par mois donc c'était le journaliste le
plus bas à peu près pareil c'est son
expérience qui nécessitent et dans les
années 2000 un ppda était payé 71 1000
euros bah quoi c'était bien parti car
émoluments ont le droit aussi galafassi
à la vitrine et il ya tout ce qui touche
alors est ce que oui ou non ce que se
trouve sur jacques legros non je trouve
que ce n'est pas toi d'abord parce
qu'effectivement il ya des tas de
périodes où ils ne travaillent pas jaqee
libye ce qu'il est remplaçant ensuite tu
désolé mais il ya une responsabilité
énorme a pas fait correctement son
boulot et qu'il dirige toute une équipe
il est le rédacteur en chef du journal
et que c'est des cd des journaux on peut
dire des grosses conneries qui peut être
lourde de conséquences donc je suis
désolé mais la responsabilité ça se
monnaye aussi après les accusations de
choc active et 7 des hommes sur
jean-michel moi je suis quand même
choqué parce que jockey parce que les
malheureusement ceux qui sont dans
l'ombre ceux qui travaillent dans
l'ombre qui sont quatre
teknys agents du centre d'un milieu de
télévision ou les journalistes qui
enquêtent sur le terrain l'écart de
salaire est trop important entre ceux
qui sont dans la lumière et ce dans
l'ombre
si l'écart était moins important ça me
choquerait pas si sedan aurait été bien
payé malheureusement l'écart est trop
important que ce forcément c'est ça le
fait que jacques legros ce sac est
scandaleux c'est le fait que là bas
c'est effectivement ce qui vient de la
descente le 100 mètres pour remonter là
bas c'est l'avenir également et kelly je
pense que c'est la faute aux mécanismes
de la télé c'est pas la faute à jacques
legros nous donne 2000 aurait prend de
1000 euros après si on compare avec les
footballeurs et footballeurs sont des
voleurs et d'autres d'autres personnes
personnalités du sport bas ce moment là
oui tout est trop où tout est pas assez
malheureusement ça fait l'écart entre
les gens qui regardent la télé et ce qui
se passe dans la télé l'écart a toujour
ete énorme même ahurissant et bas qui
les prennent ces volé à personne et je
trouve pas que c'est trop parce que si
c'est ce qu'il mérite c'est ce que la
télé juge qu'il mérite cissé volé à
personne
bah pourquoi pas et ces chiffres alors
que d'autres lui révéler leurs salaires
regarder
souvenez-vous pendant la période d gilet
jaune ya le présentateur de bfm tv
présentateur donc françois fait capillon
qui avait eu l'audace de révéler son
salaire aussi sur bfmtv regard des coûts
mais gagner c'est un discret vous
demander votre salaire net mensuel
si vous demandez votre salaire net
mensuel d'un vrai oui de combien le
siffleur 3600 assez variable la
commission de je ne sais pas voili voilà
donc ce journaliste ait payé 3600 euros
par mois voilà sur bfm tv il y en a
d'autres à ya laurent cabrol le
spécialiste météo d'ego d'europe a
expliqué sur non stop people qu en fin
de carrière il touche environ 6000 euros
par mois voilà donc qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vraiment vous moi les
arguments de tous c'est ça c'est vrai
tf1 s'est privé c'est pas c'est pas le
service public quoique même sur le
service public v mais qu'ils allongent
habille espère que mes mais quand on me
dit 2000 euros pour jacques legros s'il
fait une semaine il a pris dix milles
s'il fait un mois il a pris 40 milles
mais je peux pas dire que pour pour
mettre un costume et dire bonjour il va
pleuvoir je pense moi je dis qu'à son
avis le rouleau on n'est pas là pour
quoi c'est dû
c'est pas du bien se dire bon jeudi dans
ses sentiments son équipe on sort du bon
sens si pas pour moi un très bon centre
que je pense pour le nom de tout le
monde je parle pour moi tout seul je dis
que quand tu me dis il fait pas que ça
il est rédacteur en chef aussi donc il
est pote chômage le reste de l'année et
10000 euros pour faire une semaine dix
mille euros faute alors si tu veux des
magots faut six mois des fois pour les
gagner mais moi je pense que les mecs
sont là c'est bien tant mieux on leur
donne le costume voilà j'ai entendu
80000 euros
80000 euros par mois c'est une grosse
somme qu'à l'époque je suis obligé moi
de vous dire que c'est beaucoup c'est
maintenant 89
maintenant on lui donne tant mieux il
les prend mais pour venir une demi heure
trois quart d'heure dire bonjour il al
abahi là il a plus là bas il ya eu un
tremblement terre
c'est un travail c'est vraiment il pas
non plus son travail j'aurais juste
qu'ils changeraient pas raison a tout à
fait raison c'est absolument indécent et
cet énorme
en revanche ne ne déprécie pas leur
boulot ni parce qu'ils voudraient juste
venir mettre une veste et une cravate
ils sont là dès 8 heures du matin ils
partent à 23 heures comme vous il fait
ils font du nom mais voilà c'est juste
qu'il faut pas les mépriser en disant ça
va être une colère et cephalon mais
c'est pas du mépris ya tout à faire et
c'est pas du même jean pierre permis à
50000 euros par mois notre ami jean
pierre qui est une légende
c'est jean pierre pernaut moi je veux
dire c'est quand même la star du paf a
tant que ça puisque jacques legros il
prend 40 miles et s'appuie donc ça
donc oui je sais ça il dans à ppda
touché 71 1000 euros par mois enfin
gilles bouleau entre 20000 et 50 mais
j'ai pas compris la fourchette là parce
que parmi les cinquante mille il ya
quand même un écart c'est le grand écart
cannes laurent delahousse 15000 euros
par mois et un présentateur de bfm tv
entre 3000 et 5000 euros par mois ont
exigé les recherches de près les
genevois faut répondre à la question
mais ces chiffres ne prennent pas en
compte les primes antenne qui représente
un tiers ou un quart du salaire total
donc il faut rajouter à ça un tiers du
salaire
ceux ci ont cassé la personne les
rédacteurs de la rédaction c'est pas des
salaires confondues harris que et skull
week-end et moi j'ai une question est-ce
que ça correspond à l'audience non mais
bon ça ne fait pas d'audience vous êtes
viré
donc forcément surtout sur les chaînes
comme tf1 ou et voilà avait même même
sur france 2 maintenant laurent
delahousse son jt marche très bien
laurent de l'oxydé s'en servir et donc
forcément bien que 15000 euros mais faut
savoir que laurent delahousse aussi une
boîte de production s'est produit
ces voix la cck documentaires etc voilà
mais c'est énorme bien sûr 15000 euros
mais c'était normal ils gagnent moins
que des chaînes en quarts d'heure sur
des chaînes privées
bien entendu comme tf1 ou encore et je
ne sais pas comment ils sont payés les
gens qui font le 19 45 de m6 alors que
vous dire ça doit être énormément - et
moi je sais ça doit être aux alentours
de 8000 euros voilà ce qui présente le
jt de france 3 c'est 6000 euros brut 1
d'accord hélas bien que tu as l'air de
céder s'avère d'autant plus important
qu'il ne travaille que quatre jours par
semaine ce qu'à partir du vendredi ses
présentateurs le week-end qui travaille
bien il travaille que quatre jours par
semaine donc c'est d'écran très gros
salaires de là aussi qui est qui et que
j'adore qui fait du bon boulot c'est
vrai je dénigre pas mais c'est un un
mois c'est un an de salaire alors on
compare pas les salaires avec les
enseignants il passe à la télé machin
même nous aussi on gagne de l'argent
c'est pas ça qu'on dit mais la question
c'est est un être vous choquer moi je ne
peux pas vous dire la non ils méritent
80000 euros
parce que pour moi quelqu'un qui
présente le journal télé pour moi c'est
comme une star du foot pour moi c'est
quelqu'un qui est bien on lui voit là il
vient il se met bonjour il a le
prompteur il a son oreillette et il
prend 80 mille euros par mois 80000
euros par mois c'est c'est faux
longtemps dans ses études à la fin
d'année il a pris 800 me de plus de 800
millions à 1 million d'euros et la
précédente année monsieur bonjour il
peut adresser un million d'euros voilà
c'est sûr il faut savoir gré des moulins
du 19 45 convient d'avoir l'info c'est
14 euros par mois voilà puisqu'il avait
dévoilé également sur leurs salaires sur
le 19 45 de m6 oui à 65% envoyez-nous
qui sont pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mia 65% de téléspectateurs pensent
qu'ils seront payés à 65 ans
non c'est ça ouais ben laden mais c'est
normal d'être choqués parce qu'à
l'échelle de notre de la vraie vie mais
sa voix lyrique s'cusez moi de dire ça
moi je trouve que c'est normal d'être
choquée qu'elle a toutes les échelles
je suis désolé qu'on vous narines ou non
peut on n'est pas choqué forcément c'est
vrai que je suis sûr que les les
cadreurs et les personnes qu il est avec
nous là on va demander on va demander à
notre membre du public péroné est ce que
vous êtes choqué quand même vraiment la
vie à répondre complètement la voilà
ouais mais après je peux comprendre que
les gens qui ont vu ça comme comme visa
comme valérie ils ont vu l'envers du
décor ils ont vu les mecs arrivé à 8h du
matin ils ont vu les mecs repartir à 23h
dirigé des équipes et moi il ne veut pas
jacques loubet moi j'en veux pas non
plus à jacques legros n'y a personne
c'est privé jean jacques legros lui
propose deux mis en cause par énormément
j'en veux à personne je suis qui mena
moi le premier je suis tu me lâches et
du camion le matin et je viens ici après
mois le pr nature j'en veux pas là
dessus tout le monde a droit de gagner
son argent c'est juste répondre à la
question etes-vous choqué oui on est
choqué parce qu'on pense aussi qu'il ya
des gens qui se lève à 6h du matin et
qui finissent aussi à 20h15 à la fin il
reste que deux mille balles et qui vont
travailler dessus de l'île dimanche
parce que aussi il faut continuer après
de samedi et dimanche pour gagner de la
tune en plus c'est que ça c'est pas un
truc là comme tu dis le bon sens je n'ai
pas de bon sens mans c'est que ma tête
qui me moins 200 ce qui me fait parler
il ya encore une chance et après lui n'a
pas de bon sens je le connais un peu
non mais je connais un peu il n'a pas de